Congress is debating the first new
branch of the US military in 70 years
some lawmakers want to create a space
Corps with a mission to protect America
in outer space the Pentagon spent 22
billion dollars last year on space
defense a military base inside Colorado
Cheyenne Mountain plays a critical role
in that strategy bianna golodryga
visited the complex deep inside a cave
designed to protect the US and its
allies from attacks beyond oh good
morning good morning sorry New York but
this is truly the city that never sleeps
it is said that Colorado Cheyenne
Mountain Air Force Station acts like the
human brain stem the survival bunker
pulls in information makes sense of it
and passes it along to the brain or our
country's decision-makers there's also
good reason Cheyenne Mountain is known
as America's fortress it is the the
nerve center for the the blanket of
defense for the u.s. that nerve center
is here in Colorado Springs an
impenetrable fortress beneath 2,000 feet
of granite Colonel Robert moose commands
the 720 first Mission Support Group at
Cheyenne Mountain we provide 24/7
Global watch on all ballistic missile
threats the sensors that are global are
feeding data into Cheyenne Mountain
descent processed and disseminated to
the national leaders this complex was
built at the height of the Cold War in
the 1950s and 60s to defend against
long-range Soviet bombers the race to
destroy one another Cold War tensions
have since thawed but Russia and China
are developing technology that could
disable or destroy America's satellites
and North Korea has launched a litany of
missile tests is this facility still
equipped to handle what we've seen
happened throughout the last 40 years it
is designed to be a survivable
high-altitude electromagnetic pulse
certified facility that will survive any
threat to North America right now the
underground bunker is survivable so that
the various government agencies inside
can surveil the skies and provide
security to the US and Canada
if a foreign country attacks the
American heartland to 25-ton doors would
seal the mountain and everyone inside
the base within 40 seconds since the
Cold War has there ever been a need or a
threat or a scare to where both doors
have been closed September 11th 2001 is
the only time they've ever been closed
there was an aircraft out of San Diego
that we'd lost contact with it was
heading towards Colorado so we closed
the blast doors this is a small
underground windowless city there is a
hospital and a fire department
firefighter Carrie Thompson runs drills
so he and his colleagues are prepared to
respond to any medical emergencies we
went up there and secured him to a
backboard and brought him down and that
we've heard has actually happened
absolutely yes it's something that we
train on and it happens if there is a
seismic event like an earthquake
more than 1,300 rolled steel springs
isolate the building's the building's
will just sway in their chambers and
still continue to go on mission despite
the gravity defying efforts gravity
takes over and refills the reservoir
force some congressional leaders accuse
the Pentagon of not doing enough to
prioritize space the House adopted a
version of the National Defense
Authorization Act this summer which
calls for the creation of a new combat
ready space core by 2019 the Senate's
version of the bill prohibits this
pitting the two chambers on a collision
course over space so the first
indication of our launch comes from from
our satellites General J Raymond heads
up US Space Command and is opposed to
creating a separate space core how
worried are you and what do you say to
those who may argue that we've dropped
the ball the Air Force has been leaders
in space for over 60 years we have the
world's best space capabilities without
a doubt and today there's nothing we do
as a joint force that isn't enabled by
space our potential adversaries have had
a front-row seat and have watched us
integrate space capabilities to great
advantage and to be honest they probably
don't like what they see